do you agree the Espionage Act outlines
certain things you can and can't do with
classified material yeah do you agree on
an audio don't you agree same thing for
bug because we don't have evidence that
he did the same things Trump did not
only did he do he had no authority to do
it as vice president he obstructed an
investigation you can classify anything
he wanted as president but this piece of
direct can't do anything but as vice
president do you understand let's bring
the heat down and just let me ask an
honest question in the recording that's
been released now you can hear Trump
saying this is still classified I could
have Declassified as president but I
didn't know okay he didn't know no no he
didn't know he did know it doesn't
matter he already talked to the FBI
months earlier I said give us the
documents give us a document help you
not a problem you guys are creating a
mountain out of a mobile because you
don't want them to run that's how stupid
you are you're afraid that all of this
is going to materialize on a much bigger
scale than he gets elected that's why
you guys can't handle it this guy is
really a piece of work